here's the story like this is a story
from uh
uh uh tips for online dating how to keep
yourself safe in 2022 sure we'll start
there and then we'll see
uh where we go from there tips for
online dating how to keep yourself safe
in 2022 wedding stats and netflix junkie
number one get contact details
collect some basic information about
them even if it's just an email address
phone number you need more than two
their photo and username to go on the
site where you met number two follow
their online footprint
comb social and google it's not too late
to bail if you uh unearth concerning the
information three video chat your date
before meeting them pretty interesting
four
know the most common red flags are they
ranting against blm or another movement
as you've met are they judgmental of
someone of a group of individuals you
learn a lot about them five
delete them when in doubt six drive
yourself or take public transportation
seven
let someone know where you are uh as
you're going on the date whatever it is
you're doing don't go without people
know where you are so
people nowadays are dating in a
different way it's no longer hey meet
mary i met mary and it's how people meet
it's today
i know people who have met on
match.com
who are in long-term relationships and
married it's kind of successful
successfully wonderful human beings
and
you know i
was never in the mix to do that
but that's how people meet today
and there's nothing wrong with it but
you have to remember my overarching rule
which is if you don't know somebody in
real life you don't know them
right so just because somebody says
they're a wealthy
physician and they drive this car and
they live there that doesn't mean
anything online
and those
guidelines those suggestions are very
good ones for safety
because
it is a
tremendous opportunity for scam artists
you know we've seen the tinder swindler
on
netflix i'm working on right now one
right now where 40 women
were courted by one fellow
they're all in their 20s
and
each one of them was physically
or sexually assaulted by this guy
and then harassed
they all got together online started
telling their stories to each other
put together a case interesting handed
it to me
essentially with a bow on it for a story
that we are now shooting
and this guy was operating on facebook
he was operating on other social media
platforms but he was able to
gain the confidence of these women
the money that he took from them was not
as big as the tinder swindler
but the the sexual violence
the physical violence the abuse and
harassment
is far worse i think
so it does he know you're you're up to
what you're up to or not yet he's got it
so you haven't yet started the
investigation we're interviewing victims
right now really starting next week so
how did these so how did these folks
reached out to me on social media i know
but how did the 40 find each other well
somebody posted
beware of this guy
he's a bad guy this is what he did to me
and somebody saw that and said oh me too
and then suddenly there are
38 40 women old smokers with the same
same story
now before we move on the tinder
swindler i mean this is taking over
netflix is taking people are talking
about this left and right great story
what are your thoughts on that story
well i think you know this guy's gotten
away with a lot of bad stuff
right he is a great con man
and i think it was brave for these women
to come forward because it's hard to do
that it's hard to realize you've been
scammed but this guy was very good i
mean he had the whole back story he had
you know do you want to get on my
private plane and fly to albania with me
i mean
you could see how
an intelligent successful woman
might buy into that
you know everybody's gotta every date
starts with the first date right
everybody's got a little bit of puffery
in them right
but
not to this level right you know i think
this rock once said uh
on your first date you don't show up
yourself you send your representative
right
so but he got caught this guy the tinder
swindler right but what's amazing to me
is
how few criminal charges he's faced now
again i get he's overseas and now
there's some civil action that's been
taken by the family he claimed to be
right
of family yeah the the uh jewel people
and uh and i guess he did 15 months or
something like that on a related charge
but it's hard to prosecute these people
i mean we we once did a series
on online scammers you know to catch a
con man and some of this stuff was
nigerian based and
the network gave me
a year and a half
and access to three or four different
producers who would rotate in and out
and it took that long to smoke these
guys out of nigeria because they
typically work
or in west african cafes and they don't
come out they try to get you to send the
money
and finally
after more than a year with
uh aliases and names like you know jimmy
de money and rich greenback and you know
kind of a tongue-in-cheek thing we got
these guys to meet us
in london where we set up a a pub with
hidden cameras and they would come and
they ran their scam and we caught them
and it was it was hard work but you
can't do that story
in a week you can't do that story every
year it was it was such a big deal
because we pulled it off but it was a
herculean task to do it and that's why
these guys get away with it it's so
ubiquitous right just the internet in
general how are you gonna the guy you're
talking about with the 40 you know the
40 uh
women that came out right the victims
that came up to you what's your approach
going to be with him
well
we're going to have to be a little bit
flexible but i think ultimately
you try to set up a sting
so maybe
the next victim who we can put in place
to make her seem like she's a good mark
set up a date
sent him to the travel expenses he shows
up i'm there she's not
confront confrontation are you worried
you're letting the cat out the bag or
well i think it's vague enough
in terms of there's so many of these
guys out there this right now
he's chris is coming for you buddy yeah
yeah
i'm that guy
i'd be moderating i'd be muttering one
person in the world you chris hansen oh
my god that's classic i i think there's
so many of these guys out there that i i
am
comfortable talking about aside from
dating i mean how many freaking bitcoin
scammers fake
valuetainment accounts fake sauce talks
money fake dvd non-verified accounts i
mean pat
you you've told this story but there
were fake chris hanson's
courting
young women to work in in
investigations into predators
they were out on social media
so what's the general rule these days
because i mean you've dealt with this i
assume non-stop we have fake
valuetainment accounts you know
messaging people
is there like a go tool like pat read
off these six seven
you know tips
but is there sort of a root you know
like the uh the rules for radicals or
rules
for online yeah
if they're on social media and they're
committing harassment or violating terms
of service for twitter or
uh instagram
you need to file the report in in in
numerous cases where
people have targeted me for harassment
or whatever
you can get that account taken down but
it's it's painstakingly difficult and to
keep track of it all it's just
give you a migraine you know because
there's so many people out there trying
to do it so
you protect yourself as best you can
there are some security people i'm sure
you've got people monitoring accounts to
see what pops up and i've got people who
monitor mine thankfully because like you
can't do it by yourself
yet you don't want somebody out there
saying you're doing something that's
untrue or creating a
misinformation campaign because people
do it every day it's not that hard to do
i mean people pop up i report accounts
all the time
that are
have my picture in my name instagram
does not do a good job of deleting
terrible by the way
they're they're
i don't i don't know if it's intentional
i don't think it's i don't know if it's
volume but they can probably do a better
job because would you say the number one
app that they're targeting would be
facebook or is it more instagram and
tick tock due to the age being younger i
think that to me in my experience
instagram has been very responsive when
i've had an issue and i've had far fewer
issues on instagram than i have on on
twitter
twitter to me at least seems to be where
there are more trolls
more people getting away with stuff
harder to report and if you were to look
at what people say about chris hanson on
instagram
is the goat he's this is that all you
know 99 positive on twitter
uh he did this murder or did you you
know it's just hold on chris are you
saying that there's trolls on twitter
is that what you're saying no
shocking breakthrough if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]